[Music]
six best-selling young adult authors
have teamed up to write a novel
celebrating black love
blackout weaves together six stories of
love and friendship
set against a massive power outage in
new york city
first on cbs this morning we invited the
six writers to come together in
conversation
they are danielle clayton author of the
bells series
tiffany d jackson author of monday's not
coming
nick stone is author of dear martin
angie thomas
is author of the hate u give ashley
woodfolk is author of the fly girls
series
and nicola yoon is author of
instructions for dancing
they gathered in harlem to discuss
collaborating during the pandemic
pandemic and the importance of
representing young people of color
in joyful love stories
i'm so excited to be here with all of
you beautiful
ladies thank you let's start with
danielle why don't you tell the story
how you roped all of us into doing
this book with you
[Music]
it's so funny how we all came together i
have a wonderful niece
she is 15 years old and she said to me
why don't the black girls
ever get big love stories why are they
always
the sidekick and i thought you're right
this is a problem
then the pandemic started and on tv
we kept seeing black people being killed
at the hands of police violence and it
was super super depressing and upsetting
and i thought
we have to have some hope and then i was
like okay
i'm just going to rope all of the people
that i love into writing a novel
together
i mean lovingly
i feel really proud about what we made
and i think that when people read it
they will see all of that love and all
of that light
which is what we needed right when we
were going through this pandemic
yeah and usually writing is like very
isolating yes yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know but this was
like this was the best group project
i've ever been a part of
yes absolutely um honestly it was like
super organic like danielle basically
was like
you're gonna do this trope you're gonna
do this trope and as
we put them together we
interwove them with characters yeah and
tiffany's
story which like really connects them
all right
that's the only way i could see this
happening i can only visualize
this book as a love actually as a
valentine's day i have so much of a
connection here
that i'm so excited to see other people
fall in love with my city and fall in
love in my city
and then we all were able to connect it
through our different characters and
different neighborhoods different
neighborhoods and stuff you really get
like the full breadth
of new york city just from tiffany's
story
and then the way our stories sort of pop
in as you get
to each act of her story not every story
in this book is a traditional love story
how do you feel like the story
kind of ties into the larger theme of
love oh yeah i try to do that in my
books show
different kinds of love because it's not
just romantic love that's great
but family love and self self love
that's a huge one for me and my stories
i think
one thing that blackout does and it does
beautifully
is that it affirms to black kids that
you can be the center of the love story
and we're telling them over and over
again that their lives matter but we're
telling them in the context of trauma
and i think that
by showing various kinds of love stories
it really brings that message home that
your lives matter
your dreams matter your love matters
your hope matters all of it
all of it matters we even got a love
story where she get to choose between
two dudes
because black kids have love triangles
as well right
yeah i've honestly never seen that until
i read
angie's story i haven't either and i
thought about that you see it in y.a all
the time the girl trying to choose
between two guys
you know that was that was twilight that
was the hunger games but we don't see it
with the black girls
yeah we don't and you did that you did
that so there are not
just one but two stories that have lgbtq
plus characters in it talk about the
importance of the literary
representation for members of the
community and especially since this is
like pride month
it's detrimental to a person's identity
to never see themselves reflected in
in a positive way so for me it's vital
to tell as many types of stories of love
stories
as possible i feel the same way i'll be
honest i think that if i had read a book
that had a queer black girl in it when i
was 15
i would have recognized the signs
the signs were everywhere and of course
like the six of us can't write to into
every single experience or every single
identity
we you know wanted to make it as
inclusive as possible
like that is why those stories are there
because we
were those kids and they deserve a great
love story just as much as everybody
else
recognizing the humanity in
all different ways of existing
yeah will just make all of us kinder
i think that if any of our readers tune
in to this interview and they look at
this and they're like
i read her book i read her book they're
all so different from one another
you know tiffany she destroys us with
her books
with her thrillers and nicola she mends
our hearts with her
love so what would you say that
you bring to blackout from your previous
work
oh i write boys
i grew up surrounded by boys and there's
something so like rich and beautiful
about black male teens
that we don't get to see yeah so like
that's what i brought i brought
my boy character i feel like i brought
if you don't know i can tell you
the feels yes yes you didn't murder
anybody
i know i'm not proud of you i feel like
i brought a change of format
i wanted to make sure that like you know
this this story had to be fired we had
to throw everything yeah
i feel like you also brought tension
which is something that you do that's a
theme
bringing suspense to a love story look
at you looking so proud
she's so proud right now i really like
to write about the power of a big love
right
to change your life so i think that's
what i bring people
knock it all the time and they knock
romantic stories and makes me so mad
yeah
because love is all there is yeah you
love your work you love your art
you love your friends love is the thing
you also brought
uh yelling at everyone to add more
kissing
you sure did yes i think we're like the
captain planet
all of our forces combined has now
created this wonderful experience
that as we move through the city and
move through the stories and meet the
characters
it comes alive wow i love that
conversation
yeah it was like we were sitting there
listening in and i think even as they
talk about the power of showing these
types of characters
there's so much power in just seeing a
piece like that and being able to feel
the nuances of how they sort of came to
uh to be and how this book came to be
well i also i love
i love the energy of all the different
perspectives coming together and the
respect they showed for
each other which was great to see i
really felt like they forgot the cameras
were there yeah yeah
we love when that happened yeah that's
when the magic happens blackout is on
sale now and you can watch an extended
version of the author's discussion on
our website that's cbsthismorning.com